fascinating thing nobody's talked about
at all other election results democrats
they are divided as they've ever been
after shocking house losses continue to
raise really serious questions about the
party's
far left socialist shift led by i would
say speaker
ocasio-congresswoman ocasio-cortez but
despite the obvious setback for her
coalition
nancy pelosi still refusing to denounce
her party's extremism
as she mounts yet another bid for
speaker kevin mccarthy says she won't
get there
and what about doom and gloom and dark
winter
basement bunker well the ever
cognitively struggling joe
how fast would he surrender to the far
left agenda it's frightening
already vowing to reverse the
president's tax cuts expand
obamacare into biden care undo the
president's orders on border security
yeah we'll be the united sanctuary
states of america
get us right back into the paris climate
accord
oh by the way on that climate accord it
calls for
uh major cuts in the use of fossil fuels
how's pennsylvania going to react to
that implement an unconstitutional
mass mandate get started on a
multi-trillion dollar climate plan
and by the way maybe shut down the
entire country some of the loudest
voices around him
shouting to defund the police pack the
court grant
statehood to d.c and elsewhere abolish
the electoral college
and the legislative filibuster look
that's a real possibility god forbid
they ever get this power if democrats
control
congress we have an important race david
perdue kelly loffler in georgia that's
on january 5th if the
senate were ever to go to the democrats
they ever got full power god help us
democrats
you know what that would mean we'd see
far left extremism like never before as
chucky says everything's on the table
bernie sanders elizabeth warren aoc
uh beto bozo setting the agenda
and also breaking tonight we're now
learning that biden plans to
tap long time aid ron klain you know the
guy that
ran the h1n1 or n1h1 as joe says
uh remember last year he said we did
everything wrong
when asked about their response to the
swine flu epi
pandemic and by the way the same guy
that headed up the gore recount effort
in 2000 that lasted 37 days
oh we forgot about that